previously on TV sins why in the world
would they stop making cookie cats
they're only the most scrumptious and
delicious ice cream sandwich ever made
waiting with a Great Pumpkin when I
could have been out for twigs or cream
I turned myself into a pickle Morty but
the garage door open I mean it's
possible Rick couldn't care less if
people know he's a mad scientist but I
usually like a little privacy when I'm
transforming my pickle I'm pickle rag
troll dilmer shalls' it's probably sin
enough that this intro scene doesn't
have an episode yet but I'm just
confused why eat but she would have a
separate face when the face is the
entire but shouldn't the butt then be
the entire face and wouldn't this make
the mouth also it's official Rick and
Morty needs to do a whole episode
including all the stuff they didn't do
from the intros and turn it into one
episode they're good at off-the-wall
concepts so time to make it happen
[ __ ] stop digging for hidden layers
and just be impressed
Rick and Morty fans in our comment
section did you do this on purpose to
get out of family counseling he did and
it really makes me wonder why he didn't
do something a lot less convoluted seems
like he could have simply faked being
sick or made himself sick for real and
had an antidote hidden somewhere or
thousands of other things he could have
done to get out of therapy
we're going to get one of the most
famous Rick and Morty episodes out of it
but well it's hard to complain it's not
hard to say hey Rick why is there a
syringe of mysterious fluid hanging
directly over you Morty's got a point
here why would Rick set up some sort of
Rube Goldberg and syringe solution in
full view of everyone I would think
someone smart enough to become an actual
pickle would also be smart enough to
hide whatever creative way they found to
not be a pickle anymore for instance
conjuring a meeseeks and asking them to
hide until everyone leaves and then
administer the antidote for one possible
solution
Beth conveniently leaves the garage door
open so the pickle Rick can get into his
adventure this goes on for some time it
was a bright ass sunny day with no cloud
in sight then the clown's with the
flooding rain came out of nowhere to
bail Rick out I'm pretty sure it only
rains long enough for Rick to get to the
next phase of the story making this the
biggest day of sex mock in Iran since
Noah when God kill all of Noah's Ark
nemec's also floods don't happen this
fast man unless the water is coming
directly from the garage this driveway
wouldn't accumulate water at any depth
at all pickle rick is apparently holding
his breath underwater so can we talk
anatomical morphing does this mean this
pickle has a respiratory circulatory and
neurological systems and if so isn't it
more of a pickle shaped human than an
actual human turned into a pickle yes
how did he say yes so clearly if he's
tonguing a Roach's brain non-stop to
make it move also most scientists think
that
arthropods actually had
a distributed intelligence which means
their motion is controlled at multiple
points of the body meaning this cerebro
Linga shouldn't really be doing all that
much at all it's nobody's choice to be
here your knobs the family was told to
get counseling by your principle sounds
like the principal was a co-writer on
the script considering the unusual
request for the entire family to get
counseling even though it's not the
family that was puffing pottery glazed
in the art room as far as my research
shows pottery glaze does not contain any
brain altering substances Oh sweet
summer child
how long have you all been eating poop
yeah but when you have fond memories of
the pickle Rick episode you don't
remember the Morty Desk peeing incident
or the teacher that eats poop do ya this
rat trap includes a weight wall screws
and bolts and a tie it off rubber bands
secured at twice a pickles height how
the hell could Rick build this at his
Kirk pickle sighs and with a distinct
lack of opposable thumbs this Rick
builds complex machinery quickly with no
hands or tools it's going to be a common
thing isn't it fine let's add five sins
for this plot for wording nonsense and
move on good thing the city installed
these sewer covers to give way with such
great sense of dramatic timing I know
this is one of those things where you're
not supposed to think very deeply and do
it and just accept that Rick who was a
pickle screw drat arms and legs onto
himself and now has the agility of Tony
Jaa
has he rampages through this rat horn
but if rat Anatomy is this amazing I
find it hard to believe they wouldn't
rule the world or at the very least have
complete control of the New York City
subways also don't get me wrong going
all John Rick chapter 3 pickle bellum on
these rats as pure amazingness but
unless he's broken the law of
conservation of mass him making this
machine appear complete with seemingly
unlimited ammo out of absolutely nothing
could suck my gherkin well dr. Wong by
the way racist name-calling thing's
races that already been racist at all
he'll have any self-awareness god it was
especially the rats now they're dead I
guess it was me you should have
impressed
I feel like somewhere this episode
should get a cent off for its goofy
premise paying off and I'll do it here I
mean to be in the piggy bastard but
what's up with all these vents in this
hallway and room 280 is directly across
the hallway from room 290 did Rick get
this deep into the middle of nowhere
from that sewer he was in can't Rick
just find a way out on his own he's been
using the vents to get around and he has
more resources than when he was down in
the sewers and down there he could build
a jetpack and a whole complicated
rapport assembly a machine some
my men are calling you Selenia the
pickle man an old wives tale he crawls
from bowls of cold soup to steal the
dreams of wasteful children this old
wives tale is about as stupid as the
First Wives Club a pickle as some sort
of waste not want not bogeyman
I know rushes up guys but it can be way
more creative and tip than that this
Russian syndicate must shop for office
supplies at the same company as John
wick and lecherous Joker
because these industrial-strength
pencils are somehow nailing someone to a
wall and impaling entire human shoulders
my pencil breaks when I press too hard
while dotting the I and Kendrick with a
little heart what do you think is in the
syringe bath you're the one that costs
$200 an hour you tell me okay so this
mandatory counseling costs $200 I can
barely even see the family agreeing to
this counseling much less paying $200 an
hour oh my god there's pictures of
people eating poop in there the
alternate title of this episode was
clearly fecal Rick as little that's left
of these desks I'm questioning their
ability to support a full Van Dam in
their current condition I was Rick
flying this chopper without being able
to reach the anti-torque pedals and
other important helicopter II things
some kind of Suicide Squad I have no
doubt that you would be bored senseless
by therapy the same way I'm bored when I
brush my teeth and wipe my ass who has
ever been wiping their ass and said to
themselves god damn this is boring it's
not like it's supposed to be fun
feels like this is just another way for
the episode of wallowing again she
huffed enamel and we never even talked
about it oh yeah he didn't it's what led
to summer saying I am mad that I can't
Huff enamel without people assuming it's
because my family sucks saying she'd
prefer people to just think she likes to
get high it was discussed
a stringed instrument will be completely
muted by crushed corpses attached to its
strings even in the key of b-flat now
for the east black Jaguar is KY I'm
gonna untie Rick and Morty competitive
endurance to tickling you know is this
the first part of some kind of magic
trick lusion michael hmm trick is
something up or does for money god
dammit I love myself dad I would like
you to tell me what's in the syringe I'm
a pickle when I feel like it so you
asked well actually nobody on this
planet ever really chooses each other I
mean it's all a question of quantum
physics molecular attraction and timing